Das Wald als Rufe zu fuhr, das Wald als Rufe zu fuhr, mit Flügel und Stiftung, das Wald schlief für Spass, das Wald schlief für Spass. Das Wort schrieb für Spaß. 2020 an, da habe ich das Gefühl ein bisschen. Oh, im nächsten Jahrhundert, ha ha ha. Dieser Jahreswechsel macht mich jetzt schon wahnsinnig. Herzlich willkommen. Oh mein Gott. Ja, herzlich willkommen. Herzlich willkommen zur letzten Das-Podcast-Ufo-Folge des bärmlichen Jahres 2019. Endlich ist dieses Drecksjahr zu Ende. Hallo Stefan. Dieses Drecksjahrhundert ist vorbei, denn wir erwarten jetzt das nächste Jahrhundert, was für alle Väter in diesem Land auf jeden Fall sehr viel Bühne bietet für tolle Sprüche auf den Silvesterfeiern, wo ich jetzt schon sehr viel Angst vor habe. Und wenn ich noch einen Menschen sehe, der sagt, wir sehen uns dann im nächsten Jahrhundert, dem haue ich ins Gesicht. Das ist mein Credo dieses Jahr. Es ist ja sogar das nächste Jahrtausend eigentlich schon, oder? Technisch gesehen ist es ja schon das nächste Jahrtausend. So, jetzt hol ich das raus. Das heißt, du kannst zum Silvesterabend sagen, kannst du sagen, willst du noch ein Bier? Nee, ich warte mal aufs nächste Jahrtausend. Oh mein Gott, oh mein Gott, das funktioniert nicht. Das funktioniert im zu grossen Delay.
Oh mein Gott.
Ich habe das Gefühl, wir sind, kennst du diese Spiele, wo du so Unterkörper hast von verschiedenen Monstern und so Oberkörper und dann kannst du so die lustigen Oberkörper auf die falschen Unterkörper tun und dann sieht es lustig aus. und so habe ich das Gefühl wird diese Podcast-Folge auch.
Das, was ich sage, passt so halb zu dem, was du gesagt hast,
aber es entsteht vielleicht dadurch was Neues. Das habe ich auch, ja. Ich habe ein bisschen das Gefühl, es pendelt sich vielleicht jetzt gerade ein. Du hast gesagt, lass uns mit der Aufnahme noch warten, lass uns erst mal das Internet, oh mein Gott. Ja, ich habe gerade schon gesagt, wir müssen das Internet erst ein bisschen warm laufen lassen, weil ich glaube, bei Skype ist es so, der checkt immer, ah, wird es ein langes Gespräch oder nur so ein kurzes, hey Leute, wir treffen uns später und ich glaube, so nach zehn Minuten merkt er, oh, das wird ein langes Gespräch, lass uns da noch ein bisschen Kohlen reinschaufeln, dass sie eine gute Verbindung haben. Wir können aber auch einfach mal jetzt entscheiden, das Problem anzugehen, aktiv und uns vielleicht anzurufen. Das ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen besser, oder? Wollen wir das mal machen?
Call in? Verbindung haben. Wir können aber auch einfach mal jetzt entscheiden, das Problem anzugehen, aktiv und uns vielleicht anzurufen. Das ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen besser, oder? Wollen wir das mal machen? Call-in? Ja, ich ruf dich jetzt an. Oh, das ist spannend, weil ich habe zu Weihnachten ein neues Handy bekommen und ich weiß noch gar nicht, welchen Klingelton das Handy hat, weil ich habe noch keinen eingestellt. Das heißt, das ist der erste Anruf, den ich mit meinem Handy bekomme. jetzt kann ich gleich mal checken, welchen Klingelton er hat. Ich hoffe, es ist Crazy Frog, ich hoffe ja, dass Apple endlich zur Besinnung kommt und als Werkseinstellung den Crazy Frog nimmt, statt dieses Xylophon. Na ja, noch kommt nix. Freizeichen? Ah ja, hallo Stefan. Hallo Florentin, es ist ein bisschen besser, weil so höre ich dich jetzt fantastisch. Wobei, ehrlich gesagt nicht, du klingst wie Peter Urban beim Eurovision Song Contest zugeschaltet aus Israel. Das ist ja sowieso mein Traum eigentlich, was diese Zeitversetzung angeht, dass wir mal so eine Podcast-UFO-Folge machen, wo wir unsere Spuren separat aufnehmen und dann einfach zusammentun. Also meine Spur aus Folge 186 und deine Spur aus Folge 12. Und dann legen wir die einfach übereinander. Also eine Gedächtnisfolge, wo eine Spur wird nur aufgenommen und der andere redet danach so grob drüber, wo er glaubt, welches Thema da war und welcher Gag da war. Und dann legt man das mal einfach drüber, wie du schon sagst, so eine Tesafilm-Folge, weißt du, so eine, wir kleben einen anderen Schwanz an eine andere Kuh dran und gucken mal, was passiert. Das ist immer noch das schönste Spiel, das die Generationen von Kindern in helle Aufregung gebracht hat. Da gab es noch keine Playstation, kein GTA, da musste man halt einen Kuhkörper mit einem Pferdekopf und das war's dann halt auch. Ja, man hat sich kaputt gelacht, man lag auf dem Boden mit tränenden Augen, weil man nicht glauben konnte, wie lustig denn bitte so eine Kuh mit einem Giraffenhals aussieht und auch ja, ich bin auch noch ganz entzückt davon, zumal man sagen muss, dass Kühe und Giraffen eine ähnliche Musterung haben, nur der eine ist eher so erdtönig und Kühe sind halt so all in schwarz-weiss. Aber achtet mal drauf, Giraffen haben auch dieses krasse Muster. Ja, die Evolution ist faul, die verwendet einfach alles. Ich meine, allein die Tatsache, dass eine Biene das gleiche Fell hat wie ein Tiger, merkt man glaube ich schon, dass da die Evolution einfach mal ein Auge zugedrückt hat und gesagt hat, ach, keine Ahnung, wie sieht eine Biene aus, keine Ahnung, gibt es lila, orange gestreift, nee, komm, fuck it, einfach nimm den Farbcode vom Tiger und leg das da drüber, passt schon, komm, wir machen Feierabend. Das passt schon. Aber ich finde, so eine Folge ist sehr gut zwischen den Jahren, sehr sinnbildlich, weil wir sind ja gerade beide, also ich bin in meiner Kinderstube, ich bin in meinem alten Kinderzimmer zurückgekehrt, ich schaue gerade auf so ein verträumtes Kamen, der Frost hat sich noch so ein bisschen auf den Rasen gelegt und man muss natürlich sagen, Glasfaser ist hier immer noch ein Fremdwort, das Internet ist auch noch Neuland und wir haben hier, ich bin gerade in einer Wohnung, wo sämtliche, ja ich sag mal, ansatzweise der Informationstechnologie zuzuordnende Geräte nicht funktionieren. Und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen sinnbildlich, weil die Kinder ziehen ja dann, kommen nach Hause über Weihnachten und Neujahr, um die IT-Probleme ihrer Eltern zu lösen. Und das, wie man an unserer Verbindung hört, haben wir beide nicht hinbekommen. Was ich finde, ich sehr sinnbildlich für immer für Weihnachten.
Weil ich komme immer so gross schnäuzig her.
Ja, hast du auch noch diesen einen traurigen Teddybär im Zimmer, der mit leeren Augen nicht anstarrt, an den du damals deine Jungfräulichkeit verloren hast? Ja, der alles gesehen hat schon, auch und nichts mehr sehen will, aber nicht weiss, wie er sein Leben beendet. Bei mir ist es Lotti die Kuh und Lie die Kuh war sogar ein bisschen ein einfacheres Opfer, weil sie hatte unten so ein Loch, weil man sie mit der Hand steuern konnte. Weißt du, sie war quasi so eine Handaufsetzpuppe, aber hat aber nicht an ihrer Teddyhaftigkeit verloren. Und man konnte einfach die Hand unten reinstecken und die bewegen, Ärmchen und Gesicht bewegen, war aber deswegen, muss man wirklich sagen, ein einfaches Opfer. Ist das Victim-Shaming, was du da gerade machst eigentlich? Ich weiss nicht, meiner Meinung nach war das Nein nicht ganz eindeutig. Das Muu war nicht, Muu heisst Muu, heisst es ja in der Kuh-Szene oft. Ja, aber ist ja Muu, ist nein Muu, ist beides Muu, ich weiss es nicht, Herr Richter. Und Sie, Geschworenen, muh. Bei mir ist es gerade anders. Ich bin nicht mehr in der trauten Umarmung meiner Kindheit, sondern ich bin im Hotel. Ich bin Jet Set High Life Globetropper Hotel unterwegs und es ist eigentlich ganz geil, weil ich mag es immer total gerne, wenn man mal so ein bisschen länger im Hotel ist. Und länger ist für mich alles länger als eine Nacht, weil normalerweise ist es so, gerade bei unseren Live-Shows oder so ist es oft so, wir fahren irgendwie nach Stuttgart, eine Nacht Hotel, fahren zurück. Aber mal so zwei Tage, drei Tage, vielleicht mal vier Tage im Hotel ist das Schönste, was es gibt. Es ist so geil, du hast deine eigene Welt für dich. Aber eine kleine Welt, das ist eine überschaubare Welt. Das finde ich immer bei Hotels. Du hast so sehr wenig Dinge, über die man sich kümmern muss. Also eine Pflicht, ein Schrumpf und so auf ein Minimum. Ist ein bisschen, ist nicht ganz so geil wie Krankenhaus, aber fast so geil. Weil du hast so sehr wenig zu tun und es wird dir sehr viel gemacht. Und du musst eigentlich nur da hinkommen, um zu schlafen. Ja, und es ist so ein bisschen wie Robinson Crusoe, so Castaway, weil du hast so diese kleine Insel in deinem Hotelzimmer und ich versuche das meiste aus allem rauszuholen. Ich habe dann irgendwie zum Beispiel, also das Inventar ist dann ja immer sehr unterschiedlich und ich habe hier so einen kleinen Wasserkocher und zwei kleine Löffel. Das ist alles, was ich an Besteck habe, zweiwei kleine Löffel und einen Wasserkocher. Und du überlegst, was kann
ich machen? Kann ich Spaghetti in diesem
Wasserkocher kochen? Du versuchst die
Dinge neu... Nein, also
tatsächlich nicht. Und die Antwort ist immer nein, was auch
sehr befreiend ist. Du hast kaum Möglichkeiten.
Am Ende bist du gezwungen, irgendwie
Demax, dem Demax zu gucken auf dem
Fernseher, das ist ja auch okay, der
möglicherweise auf eins liegt.
Ja, Demax, Eurosport und dann Al Jazeera. Das ist so die Reihenfolge in der Hotel Welt. Al Jazeera, ja, ja. Und ich habe keinen Kühlschrank, was auch unangenehm ist, aber es ist ja momentan Dezember, also relativ kalt draußen, aber im Hotel hat man ja oft so diese Suizidfenster, die man nicht ganz aufmachen kann, gerade so über dem ersten Stock oder sowas, damit da auf gar keinen Fall was passieren kann, sondern man kann die nur kippen.
Aber ich war gestern wirklich am Höhepunkt meiner MacGyver-Fähigkeiten angelangt. Da habe ich nämlich eine Flasche Mate an einer Schnur ganz oben an das gekippte Fenster, wo es am meisten offen ist, da habe ich die Flasche durchgemacht, am Faden runtergelassen, aufs Fensterbrett außen, Fenster geschlossen, damit die Mateflasche gekühlt wird und sie dann wieder an der Schnur hochgezogen. Ich finde es so toll, dass du deinen messerscharfen Intellekt dafür nutzt, Mateflaschen für dich zu kühlen in Hotelzimmern, anstatt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, Krebsmittel zu öffnen. Nee, nee, nee, nee, und das ist so toll, weil einerseits hast du so dieses Baumhausfeeling, andererseits bist du halt in einem modernen Hotel, und ich mag es ja auch, wenn man so sich die Situation zu eigen macht, wenn man dann genau weiß, ah, wann muss ich zum Frühstück, wo gibt es das beste Croissant, wann, also dass du das irgendwann so gut kennst alles, wo Leute nur so durchgehen, du kannst
genau wissen, welchen Knopf du drücken musst.
Ja, du hast diesen Blick, du hast dieses Selbstbewusstsein,
du betrittst den Frühstücksaal auch mit so einem gewissen
Ich bin hier schon seit einem Monat, so einem
Feeling, weißt du, so einem, du kommst immer mit
Jonghose runter und machst dich nicht mehr schick
fürs Frühstück, so das ist auch, irgendwann
ist das so angekommen. Ich finde auch, dass
das Interessante bei Schauspielern auch immer, ich achte immer drauf, wie sehr kaufe ich denen ab, dass sie in diesem Haus wohnen. Also gerade so bei Filmen, wo es um Ehepaare und so geht, die ja in diesem Haus so eine gewisse Routine haben, finde ich es immer total spannend, weil das finde ich mit am schwierigsten zu spielen, diese subtile, man kommt ja anders in einen Raum, wenn man da schon ewig war und vielleicht so einen Großteil deines Lebens verbracht hat.
Dann gehst du ja anders mit dem Raum um. Du guckst gar nicht mehr, du greifst nach Dingen, du haust auf Lichtschalter, ohne hinzugucken usw. Das finde ich gar nicht so einfach zu spielen, weil diese Schauspieler sind ja dann vielleicht am ersten Drehtag zum ersten Mal in diesem Raum und müssen damit umgehen, als wären sie da seit zwölf Jahren. Das stimmt total, allein wie du eine Tür aufmachst, ist total unterschiedlich, ob
du das schon das tausendste Mal oder das fünfte Mal machst. Einfach wie du es machst, wie du die Schritte anlegst, wie du gut durch die Tür kommst und alles kann man tatsächlich gut ablesen. Aber so ist es bei mir. Ich habe mittlerweile alles durchgespielt und ich habe mich auch gut vorbereitet, weil oft sind solche Situationen auch eine Sache der Vorbereitung. Und zwar habe ich zum Beispiel kleiner Hotel-Hack für alle da draußen, die vielleicht mal so ein, zwei Tage im Hotel vor sich haben. Ich habe mitgenommen ein HDMI-Kabel. Wow. Jetzt denkt ihr, Moment, das ist ja unglaublich, das ist ja brillant, ist es auch. Denn du hast diesen Fernseher, aber du hast es gerade schon angesprochen, da läuft nur Schwachsinn. Du hast so das gesamte Fernsehprogramm der Welt, aber du merkst irgendwann, ja, Fernsehen ist halt scheiße, du sämst rum und denkst, oh geil, Game of Thrones, das ist halt deutsch, so kannst du dich nicht anschauen. Und du sämst halt rum und denkst dir, wow, Doctor Strange, hab ich noch nicht gesehen, ah, deutsch, ja, gut, egal. So, und dann denkst du dir, aber Moment mal, ich hab hier diesen Plasma-Fernseher und ich hab ein HDMI-Kabel dabei, schliesslich schön Laptop an, schön Herr der Ringe, schön Gimli, zack, wie ich es will und kann das Beste aus beiden Welten nutzen. Ich habe das gesamte Programm der Welt. Das ist ja super. Aber auf dem Fernseher. Ich finde es sehr gut, auch liebe Grüße an den schönen Kollegen Tommy Schmidt, den guten Freund Tommy Schmidt, der nach dem Hotel immer eine Mehrfachsteckdose mitnimmt. Was ich auch gar nicht so schlecht finde, ehrlich gesagt. Weil man hat begrenzte Plätze, Stromplätze, und es fühlt sich ein bisschen blöd an, es fühlt sich auch sehr deutsch an, muss man sagen, eine Mehrfachsteckdose mitzunehmen in ein Hotelzimmer. Aber es ist einfach eine gute Idee. Es ist wie, aber ich kann mich, auch wenn es für eine gute Idee halte, würde ich es glaube ich nicht machen, weil ich würde auch gar keine, ich nehme auch keine Tupperdose mit hin irgendwo, weil ich finde, das ist alles, das ist noch nicht da, da bin ich noch nicht in meinem Leben angekommen.
Ich finde, dann würde ich, das ist so wie, ich bin, habe im Buch ein paar Kapitel zu weit da vorne geblättert und habe jetzt schon so ein bisschen reingelugt, was da noch passiert bald, aber da bin ich noch nicht, weißt du, es fühlt sich nicht natürlich an, diese Dinge zu machen. Ich will erst noch Fehler begehen, ich will erst noch ein bisschen in meinem Kapitel 8 rumschwirren und ich möchte noch nicht so gut vorbereitet sein. Ich finde, es gehört auch ein bisschen dazu, sich dann so ein Hotelzimmer unterzuwerfen und da muss man halt einfach auch haushalten mit seinen Ladekabeln. Total, vor allem die Steckdosen sind immer sehr weit voneinander entfernt, also du hast schon genug Steckdosen in so einem Hotelzimmer, Aber die sind alle ganz weit voneinander weg. Du hast am Bett eins, ist ja klar. So, wer braucht denn mehr als eine Steckdose am Bett? Und dann hast du noch eine im Bad, eine im Flur und eine an der Kleiderstange. Und dann musst du halt dein Laptop irgendwie, Laptopkabel quer durchs Zimmer, Ladekabel, Bluetooth-Kopfhörer irgendwie im Bad. Am Ende sieht es ein bisschen aus wie so ein Ocean's Eleven-Finale, einfach so nur statt den Laserpointern, hast du dann einfach sehr viele Kabel so durchs Zimmer gespannt, dann ist eine grosse akrobatische Leistungicht aufsteigt und sich denkt, okay, jetzt bin ich besser, als ich davor war. Und heute Morgen kam mir der Gedanke, der vielleicht mir ein solches Aufsteigen ermöglicht. Und ich dachte mir, darf man in Hotels das Frühstück mit aufs Zimmer nehmen? Oh ja, ich, ach ja, aber das sind diese gefährlichen Gedanken. Ja, ich weiß. Was kommt jetzt? Du hast diese Idee, aber was jetzt damit anfangen? Willst du jetzt zum Hotelpersonal gehen und die fragen, ob du das mitnehmen kannst? Nein. Willst du das einfach mitnehmen und riskieren, dass du public-shamed wirst? Nein. Ja, das ist die alte Frage, dieses, wenn man fragt, dann kann man Nein bekommen, wohingegen, wenn man es einfach macht macht kann man danach sagen wusste ich nicht das ist immer das problem das ist auch so ein bisschen oft wir kriegen manchmal mails so dürfen wir das und das aus eurem podcast verwenden oder dürfen wir das aus diesen den soundbite verwenden und ich denke mir immer so nie gemerkt ich denke mir also nett dass ihr so doof zu fragen. Mach's einfach. Was können wir tun? Thais auf euch hetzen oder was? Die hat ihr Jurastudium noch nicht mal angefangen. Was sollen wir dagegen tun? Nichts, gar nichts, wir können nichts tun. Aber wenn ihr fragt, dann können wir sagen, nee, lass mal so und dann kann man es nicht machen, weil dann weiß die Person, dass es nicht machen darf. Deswegen einfach machen Leute, einfach machen, nicht lange fragen und danach sagen, vor Gericht kann man... Aber jetzt hast du gerade die Erlaubnis erteilt. Und jetzt haben wir vor Gericht auch kein Leverage mehr. Nee, immer wenn mich jemand fragt, sage ich nein, egal was es ist, aber erst mal machen, deswegen, aber genau die Denkweise habe ich auch bei dem Frühstücksding, ob ich es nicht einfach mal machen soll, weil ich habe immer noch keinen Bock, da mit den ganzen Leuten da rumzusitzen, und deswegen denke ich mir, warum nicht, ich muss halt nur einmal an der Rezeption vorbei. Und das ist halt die Frage, wenn die halt gerade abgelenkt sind oder so, kann ich es vielleicht schaffen. Das ist für mich der Ocean's Eleven-Modus, wo ich dann irgendwie schon meine drei Croissants und meinen Schokopudding dann auf dem Tablett habe. Und dann den richtigen Moment abpassen muss und dann irgendwie Cover Camera One, Cover Camera Two und dann durch und dann schön in der Aufzug. Hast du die Musik auf dem Ohr? Klaust aber nur ein Croissant. Das ist dann auch irgendwie die grosse Fallhöhe. Schön, dass du aufsteigst in deinem Leben. Schön, dass du aufsteigst in deinem Leben. Bei mir dreht es sich im Kreis die letzten Tage, weil wie gesagt, ich bin nach Hause gezogen, um die IT-Probleme zu lösen und es hat natürlich nicht funktioniert.
Ich bin dann immer, man kommt dann mit so einer gewissen Städter-Überheblichkeit auch hier an und macht sich über diese IT-Probleme lustig.
Ich zum Beispiel musste jetzt für meine Mutter einen Laptop in Betrieb nehmen und ich dachte die ganze Zeit, ja, das kannst du auch alleine und so weiter, hab dann alles eingerichtet und dann ging natürlich das Internet nicht.
Aber auch hier erstmal, ein Stefan gerät natürlich nicht in Panik, sondern ist er ja gewohnt, aber es passiert ja ständig so. Und dann hat man die üblichen Sachen, die man macht und man wird schon so ab Router ein aus, wird man dann schon irgendwann nervös, weil dann irgendwann gehen dann jetzt auch die Mittel aus, diese typischen drei Mittel, die man immer macht, WLAN am Laptop ein und aus, Router kurz aus und an, dann wird es auch schon brenzlig, irgendwann ist man dann schon auf Eis. Und dann wird es sehr seltsam, weil alle anderen Geräte im Haus konnten sich mit dem Router verbinden und hatten Internet. Der PC hat aber auch funktioniert, wenn ich dem zum Beispiel einen Hotspot gemacht habe mit meinem Handy. Das heißt, sowohl der Router hat einwandfrei funktioniert, als auch der Laptop hat eigentlich einwandfrei funktioniert. Dieser spezielle Laptop kam nur mit meinem speziellen Internet-Router nicht klar. So, und dann fängst du an, oh nein, jetzt kommen die Hotlines. So, und dann weißt du aber nicht, welche Hotline. Habe ich erst die Windows-Hotline angerufen, dann habe ich die Dell-Hotline angerufen, dann habe ich die Telekom-Hotline angerufen. Alle waren verzweifelt, wussten nicht mehr, was zu tun ist. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich tun soll. Und dann, das waren jetzt drei Tage Tränen, wo ich einfach versucht habe, irgendwelche Einstellungen zu verändern. Und ich glaube, irgendwann hat mich auch der Telekom, die Telekom-Service-Kräfte haben mich auf dem falschen Fuß erwischt, weil ich bin ja eigentlich sehr freundlich. Ich will ja, dass die mir helfen. Und ich halte davon gar nichts, gemein zu sein oder fies zu sein, zu überarbeitet mit Servicepersonal, weil ich denke, dann helfen die einem noch weniger. Deswegen komme ich immer so auf Knien an und so und erkläre es immer ganz, ganz, ganz detailliert und Schritt für Schritt, was das Problem ist. Aber bei spätestens bei der dritten Service-Hotline hast du ja ja gar keinen nerv mehr dazu und der muss mich einfach für den grössten arschloch gehalten haben weil dann kommen so tipps wie er macht den router ein und aus und bevor er den satz zu ende spricht sage ich schon ja das habe ich vielleicht schon dreimal gemacht und man wird dann auch sehr wütend und es ist dann auch nicht zielführend das weiß ich auch aber jetzt mittlerweile ist das problem noch nicht gelöst und ich weiß nicht was ich tun soll. Und das Problem ist, und da wurde es dann wirklich, da wurde es vom worse to even worse to catastrophe, als dann es plötzlich einen Abend funktioniert hat, aus dem Nichts, keine Einstellung wurde geändert, da hat es dann funktioniert. Hoffnung ist kifft, sag ich im Moment. Nein, ja, genau, es ist wie so eine Dramaturgie, es holt dich nochmal auf den höchsten Punkt, dich dann nochmal tief fallen zu lassen und danach hat es wieder nicht funktioniert. Das ist aber nicht so, ich habe jetzt nicht das Gefühl, ah cool, es funktioniert ja vielleicht, sondern ich habe eher das Gefühl, jetzt folgt dieses Problem gar keinen Regeln mehr. Es ist ja nicht so, ich dachte immer, IT-Probleme sind auch ein bisschen wie Mathematik, es gibt eine klare Lösung, aber Gleichungen funktionieren da immer nicht oder immer, aber die können nicht zwischen 18 und 22 Uhr funktionieren. Es macht das Problem so unmittelbar krasser und deswegen, ich bin verzweifelt, ich weiß nicht, ich habe auch immer noch so eingetrohene Tränen auf meiner Wange. Ich glaube, IT-Probleme sind nicht wie Mathe, sondern wie so ein Kleinkind. Es ist nervig, es ist laut, du verstehst es nicht und du musst einfach warten, bis es irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen einfach vorbei ist. Viel schütteln, sehr viel schütteln auch und draufhauen. Auf gar keinen Fall schütteln. Ich war letztens wieder im Kino und habe da wieder die Kinowerbung gesehen, schütteln Sie Ihr Kind auf keinen Fall. Machen Sie, was Sie wollen, schlagen Sie es, stecken Sie es unter Wasser, aber auf gar keinen Fall schütteln. Sucht euch ein anderes Wort. Es gibt für alles irgendwie ein anderes Wort. Konkursionen für Gehirnenschütterung oder sowas. Sucht euch ein anderes Wort für Schütteln. Schütteln klingt süss. Du schüttelst Getränke. Du schüttelst Rasseln. Du schüttelst Hände. Ja, das ist was Freundliches. Kinder schütteln klingt nach grossem Spaß, ja. Aber meint er dir an der Technik-Hotline nicht auch so ein bisschen, pass auf Kollege, es ist 25. Dezember, du bist bei deinen Eltern, das Internet funktioniert nicht. Da musst du jetzt mal schön alleine durch, ja? Da kannst du mich nicht anrufen, da muss jeder alleine durch. Ja, aber ich dachte, das ist ganz interessant, ich komme halt mit so einer wahnsinnigen Großstadt, Millionenstadtüberheblichkeit hier aufs Land, scheitere daran, und dann habe ich jetzt noch unserem Kollegen bei der Firma geschrieben, unserem IT-Systemadministrator, der auch richtig Bock drauf hat, um 15 Uhr am 25. Ja, und ich habe mich sofort entschuldigt, ich habe gesagt, ja, es tut mir total leid und ich würde mich auch nicht bei dir melden, wenn nicht schon alles probiert worden wäre. Ja, die Nachricht kriegt er von allen Mitarbeitern. Ja, ich glaub auch, so jeder, ich habe jetzt einen Treiber schon achtbein installiert, ich weiß auch nicht, woran es liegt, ich habe Windows neu aufgesetzt, das funktioniert immer noch nicht. Das ist sein Weihnachten, glaube ich. Also meine große Theorie ist ja, dein Leben wird automatisch besser, wenn du einen guten ITler kennst, wenn du einen guten Anwalt kennst und wenn du einen Steuerberater kennst, vielleicht auch einen Mediziner. Wenn du brauchst ein paar Key-Persönlichkeiten in deinem Leben, so du brauchst einen Anwaltfreund, dann hast du schon mal sehr viele Probleme nicht, weil du auf kurzem Weg immer was erreichen kannst. Aber für die ist das natürlich das ganze Leben der Horror, weil die natürlich von Leuten umgeben sind, von Nutzen die umgeben sind. Und das ist natürlich interessant, weil es ist natürlich auch leicht, sich als junger Mensch über die ältere Generation lustig zu machen. Man merkt aber relativ schnell auch, dass man irgendwann selber keine Ahnung hat. Und man kann es natürlich auch umdrehen. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man bügelt oder kocht oder irgendeine Mehlschwitze macht oder sowas. Aber ich finde es dann teilweise trotzdem ein bisschen absurd, weil bei uns ist es ja immer so, mein Vater ist Programmierer und kennt sich gut mit Technik aus, Computern aus und meine Mutter halt nicht so. Und deswegen haben die immer direkt den Tech-Support dabei. Aber mein Vater ist auch mal so ein bisschen am Verzweifeln, weil meine Mutter sagt dann zum Beispiel, ja, jetzt sind alle Mails weg. Und was es tatsächlich ist, ist, dass bei dem Ordner, bei Mac ist es ja so, dass du vor Ordnern hast du so ein Dreieck. Und wenn du dieses Dreieck anklickst, dann geht der Ordner auf und die Inhalte werden aufgelistet, erscheinen darunter.
Und das ist das gesamte Problem, dass der Ordner auf ist und meine Mutter sieht den Inhalt und irgendwann klickt sie ausversehen auf das Dreieck und alles ist weg und muss meinen Vater rufen, der dann wieder das Dreieck aufklickt. Aber das ist halt so eine Hürde, da kommt sie nicht drüber. Sie versteht das nicht mit dem Dreieck, dass dadurch jetzt der Inhalt des Ordners aufgeht, sondern die Mails sind alle weg, die sind nicht mehr da, die sind verschwunden.
Ich hätte es auch schon mal bei, ich kann mich nicht mehr einloggen in meinen Mail-Account, der Grund war, weil meine Mutter hat dann eingegeben den Benutzernamen für das Mail-Account, das ist aber auch sowas wie T-Online Hotmail-artiges, Gmail, und sie hat es halt eingegeben, den Benutzernamen für das Mail-Account, das ist aber auch so was wie T-Online, Hotmail-artiges, Gmail, und sie hat es halt eingegeben, den Benutzernamen, und dann kam das Pop-up-Menü, weil das das Passwort erkannt hat. Also so eine Autovervollständigung. Die hatte aber, muss man sagen, zu ihrer Verteidigung, eine sehr exakte Größe des gerade noch da befindlichen Passworteingabefeldes da drunter. Das heißt, plötzlich ist das Passworteingabefeld verschwunden, weil der Rechner erkannt hat, dass sie jetzt ihren Benutzernamen eingegeben hat. Und dann kam die Autovervollständigung genau über das Passwortfeld. So, und statt jetzt einfach irgendwo hinzuklicken, damit es verschwindet, hat sie gesagt, ich kann mich nicht mehr einloggen, weil ich kann das Passwort nicht mehr eingeben. Stattdessen steht da jetzt zweimal der Benutzername. Das sind diese kleinen Dinge. Und man weiss nicht, aber es ist auch völlig, also wenn man daneben sitzt, macht man sich lustig, haha, hat alle eine gute Zeit, man lacht irgendwann drüber. Wenn man am Telefon, wenn man einen Anruf bekommt, und das ist unmöglich herauszufinden, woran das Problem ist. Deswegen lasse ich mir mal ein Foto schicken mittlerweile von dem Problem. Aber ich, wie gesagt, ich bin super verzweifelt. Und wenn irgendwer von euch weiss, woran das liegt, ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht mehr, was ich meine. Ich bin jetzt nicht dabei, den Rechner zu schicken. Nee, komm, du nutzt jetzt nicht jeden Podcast für deinen fucking Tech Support. Wir werden jetzt nicht das ganze Jahr zwei ... Ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt tun soll. Du hast schon, nicht nur terrorisierst du deine ganze Familie, sondern alle um dich herum. Da musst du einfach durch. Vor allem, man fängt erst so an mit Ja, Muttern, ich mach's dir kurz. Und setzt sich dann da hin und so und sie ist auch so ein bisschen, ja okay, ein bisschen arrogant jetzt, wie er sich hier auftritt, okay. Verzieht sich dann so in ein anderes Zimmer und zwei Stunden später ich sitze weinend an dem Rechner, weiss nicht mehr weiter, hab noch großartige Sprüche geklopft, da kommt dann gar nichts mehr, nur noch Tränen und dann bringt sie einem auch so ein Teller Plätzchen bei und der Hochstart, das Tiefe, das kippt wieder komplett um und man sitzt da und weint, danke Mama, ich weiß nicht, wo ans liegt, ich weiß nicht, alles probiert. Und das ist der Geist der Weihnacht, ist das nicht ja. Ich hasse Weihnachten. Am schlimmsten finde ich an Weihnachten übrigens den Satz, ich wünsche, frohe Weihnachten gehabt zu haben. Kommt das bei euch, ist das so ein Ruhrpott-Ding? Ne, das habe ich noch nie gehört. Das echt nicht? Hier ist es die ganze Zeit, wird jetzt nach Weihnachten auf allen Feiern, wo man ist, oder dann treffen sich ja auch viele Freundeskreise wieder zusammen, so zwischen den Jahren, auch so schlimm, sagen dann, ja, ich wünsche, frohe Weihnachten gehabt zu haben, weil es ist ja vorbei. Jesus, Futur zwei? Es ist wie frohe Weihnachten nachträglich. Ja, nee, nein, es ist, glaube ich, neukomplizierter als Futur zwei. Ist Plusquam perfekt, oder? Ich habe kein, nein, ja, vielleicht. Es ist halt abgeschlossen, es ist definitiv abgeschlossen, es ist ein bisschen wie frohe Weihnachten nachträglich, aber alle und alle grinsen dabei immer so, ob dieser
meisterleist, grammatikalischen
Meisterleistung und ich denke mir jedes Jahr
halt einfach deine dumme Klappe,
es heißt, ich hoffe du hast schöne Weihnachten,
so, das sagt man, ich hoffe du hast schöne Weihnachten,
dann kann man fragen, was an Silvester
geht und so weiter, aber frohe Weihnachten
gehabt zu haben, ist hier so ein Ding, alle sagen das und
haben dabei so ein grosses Grinsen und so ein
Monokel im Gesicht plötzlich,
weil sie das sagen. Aber ich verstehe nicht,
woher diese Redewendung kommt. Aber ich dachte mir schon,
dass es fast so eine Art Mundart-Ding ist.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Du, ich habe Weihnachten in Bayern
gefeiert, da gibt es nicht mehr das Perfekt, da gibt es nur
Mio-Haw-Maschine, Weihnachten,
G-Grummel, ja.
Also es würde auch, im Untertitel würde stehen,
unverständliches, ja,istinctive Gemurmel.
Bavarian Grumble, Bavarian Growl.
Ach ja, genau, aber wie war denn dein Weihnachten? Hast du denn schöne Weihnachten gehabt haben zu sein? Ach toll, es war richtig schön. Ich habe jetzt endlich mal den Schritt gegangen, weil ich lasse mich nicht versklaven von den knallenden Peitschen unserer Konsumgesellschaft und habe lange verzichtet, mir ein neues Smartphone anzuschaffen und hatte noch ein sehr altes. Also sehr altes heißt 2015 oder so. Ich weiß, was jetzt kommt. Es ist wirklich an den, ich hätte es auch gerne noch weiterverwendet, aber es hat irgendwann einfach nicht mehr funktioniert. Ich musste, bei mir war es mittlerweile so, wenn ich eine neue App öffnen will, muss ich eine alte schliessen, weil ich konnte nicht zwei Apps gleichzeitig offen halten. Ich hatte so wenig Speicherplatz nur noch, dass ich immer, wenn ich einen neuen Podcast runterladen wollte, einen alten löschen wollte. Und ich habe alles versucht und es war, es ging einfach gar nichts mehr. Und ich habe, ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon die Ausführung gemacht hat zu meinem scheiss Konto, wo jetzt das Konto nur noch über eine App benutzt werden kann, wo man dann so eine Tann generiert und ich konnte das halt nicht installieren auf meinem Handy, weil das Handy zu alt war und dann musste ich mir so ein... Das war sehr niedlich übrigens, das war sehr niedlich, wir waren im Backstage-Bereich in Stuttgart und ich dachte mir, was sich denn da plötzlich mit dem Augenwinkel buntes, Plastikartiges Aufleuchten und dann hatte ich kurz, Florian, ich dachte, ich habe so ein Gameboy gekauft oder sowas. Es gibt ja so viele Retro-Trends mittlerweile. Dann dachte ich mir, hä, nee, habe aber noch nicht genau hingeguckt. Und dann dachte ich, okay, vielleicht so eine Kinderkamera oder sowas, eine Einblickdrehkamera oder sowas. Und dann bin ich hingegangen zu diesem Gerät. Also ein Taschenrechnerartiges Gerät, aber so ein billiges. Nicht diese guten Casio-Taschenrechner, sondern so ein billiges, und dann kam raus, es ist ein Tann-Gerät, du hast so ein mobiles Tann-Gerät für deine Sparkassen-App jetzt besorgt, was nichts anderes kann als QR-Code-Scannen, oder? Es ist lächerlich, es ist lächerlich. Ich musste, weil ich die App nicht installieren konnte, gab es nur noch eine Alternative, die halt so eine Box zu bestellen, wo du halt jedes Mal, wenn du was überweisen willst, musst du deine Karte in diese Box stecken, dann geht eine Kamera in der Box an, damit musst du den QR-Code scannen und dann generiert dir so eine Nummer, die musst du eintippen und dann hast du es. Und es ist halt wirklich lächerlich, weil das Ding ist halt wirklich so ein Fisher-Price-Taschenrechner, mein erster Taschenrechner.
Du musst das Ding ständig dabei haben, was halt auch lächerlich, weil das Ding ist halt wirklich so ein Fisher-Price-Taschenrechner, mein erster Taschenrechner. Du musst das Ding ständig dabei haben, was halt auch lächerlich ist, und es ist wirklich einfach demütigend, es ist wirklich demütigend. Und das Tolle ist ja, dass das Ding sogar Geld kostet. Ich musste das kaufen, um weiterhin mein Konto benutzen zu können, und das Beste daran war. War es wirklich so ein Gameboy-Preis, so ein 19,99,99? Es hat wirklich 24,99. Und das Beste an der ganzen Sache war ja, dass ich das Ding online gekauft habe. Und um es online zu kaufen, musste ich eine Tarn angeben. Das berühmte Wie kriege ich das Scheren-Paket auf? Ja, genau. Phenomenon. Und das war wirklich so, wo ich dachte, jetzt wollte er mich wirklich verarschen. Einfach, das war es jetzt einfach. Und ich habe sogar den Support angeschrieben mit so einem halb sarkastischen, fast glossenhaften Stil, so ein, oh, lasst mich von meinem Abenteuer erzählen und dann konnte ich es nicht machen und lächerlich. Und zurück kam nur, ja, ihre Anfrage wird bearbeitet. Zum Glück konnte ich es dann noch über ein anderes Konto über Paypal machen, aber es ist einfach lächerlich. Und jetzt sagte ich mir, es ist vorbei, diese Knechtschaft ist einfach vorbei, ich brauche einfach ein ich brauche einfach ein neues moderne smartphone aber du willst jetzt gerade so sympathisch rüberkommen so wow du benutzt dinge bis sie kaputt sind wirklich und der support eingestellt wird aber was leute wie du vergessen dabei ist dass nicht euch das am meisten nervt dass ihr alte geräte habt alle um euch herum nervt ihr damit am meisten das ist super egoistisch nicht up to date gerätedate Geräte zu haben, weil also erstmal in der Generation Instagram, wo du derjenige bis der Fotos von mir macht, die sind da nicht zu gebrauchen. Deine Fotos sind immer schief, quer, unscharf, schwarz, gar nicht existent oder so, dann bist du auch nicht erreichbar immer, wenn man telefoniert, klingst du wirklich vom Mars zugeschaltet.
Das ist alles schlecht, weniger schlecht für dich als für uns alle. Man wartet auf dich, wenn man mit dir vom Car2Go steht oder an einem Leim-Scooter, stehst du da rum und wartet immer eine halbe Stunde, bis die App sich öffnet und so. Das ist ja nicht für mich schlimm, für dich schlimm, sondern ja für mich. Du bist daran gewöhnt, dieses Umfeld machst du wahnsinnig. Zum Beispiel auch, wie viel Lebenszeit ich, glaube ich, schon Schaffnern rausgezogen habe, die, wenn sie kommen, Fahrkarte bin und ich öffne die Bahn-App und warte halt straight 40 Sekunden lang, bis die App offen ist. Ja, aber du faszinierst ja keine Miene, weil du kennst das ja, du hast ja auch eine Erwartungszeit, das dauert jetzt zehn Minuten. Und die Schaffner werden schon so nervös und wissen nicht genau, was es ist. Der Schaffner macht oft diesen, ich gehe schon mal weiter und komme dann zu ihnen zurück Move und komme nie zurück. Also an sich ist es auch perfekt, wenn man schwarz fährt, einfach sich ein langsames Handy machen oder so eine Fake-App installieren, wo man einfach nur ein Bild von diesem Ladescreen hat und einfach sagen, ja, es lebt gerade nicht, kommen sie später nochmal. Und der kommt nie wieder, als ob der sich merken würde, welche vier Vollidioten in dem ganzen Abteil jetzt nicht hinbekommen haben, ihre Karte zu ziehen, und dann kommt er später nochmal zurück. Gar keinen Fall. Ist vielleicht eine gute Möglichkeit für Schwarzfahrer, aber ... Ja, auch, ich habe gehört in Japan, ganz kurz dazu, ich habe gehört in Japan, also hörten ja generell auch, haben die Leute Angst, auf jeden Fall vor peinlichen Situationen, unter anderem damit konfrontiert zu sein, dass man schlecht Englisch spricht vielleicht als Japaner. Das Gute ist aber, wenn du jetzt so einen schönen Schnellzug in Japan von A nach B fährst und keine Fahrkarte hast und dich mit schlechtem Englisch versuchst, da durchzuhangeln, warum du gerade keine Fahrkarte hast und eine Ausrede überlegst und so, habe ich schon aufgehört, dass es den Schaffern so unangenehm ist, in dieser Situation zu sein, auch weil
natürlich alle Japaner ein Feedfahrtickets haben, dass sie sich ganz schnell entschuldigen,
verbeugen und einfach weitergehen, weil die keine Lust haben auf dieses peinliche
Konfrontationsgespräch und natürlich es denen nicht einfallen würde, dich jetzt zu schnappen
und rauszuschmeissen irgendwo in der nächsten Haltestelle, passiert nicht. Deswegen kann man
in Japan wohl als Deutscher ganz gut schwarz fahren. Werbung. Total faszinierend, ich habe letztens gelesen, dass sogar Affen Geld verstehen können. Also denen haben Forscher so Münzen gegeben und so kleine Sachen und die konnten sie wiederum eintauschen gegen Essen und solche Sachen. Das heißt, selbst Affen verstehen Geld. Und weißt du was, wenn Affen richtig clever wären, das führt mich nur zum Schluss, dass sie nicht so weit sind wie der Mensch, aber wenn Affen richtig clever wären, dann würden sie auch ein Konto anlegen. Und zwar nicht irgendwo, sondern bei der Commerzbank. Denn da gibt es zusätzlich 100 Euro Startguthaben und eine Kreditkarte der Firma Mastercard zusätzlich on top dazu. Und 100 Euro, wie viele Bananen sind das denn? 250 Bananen? Kann gut sein, wobei die wachsen da auch umsonst am Baum, muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen. In wenigen Minuten hat man sein Konto eröffnet und wird dann auch noch kompetent beraten und wenn man sogar noch einen Freund oder Femimitglied oder sonstiges Haustier oder was auch immer dazu überzeugen kann, auch ein Konto zu starten, dann kriegt man noch 100 Euro obendrauf. Ja, schliesst heute das Konto über die schnellste Kontoeröffnung Deutschlands in nur wenigen Minuten.
Du kannst es abschliessen, vollkommen digital auch.
Und das Beste, ihr müsst
euch keine aufwendige URL mit
HTTPS etc. merken. Ihr könnt einfach
auf ufo.commerzbank.de
gehen und findet da alle Informationen
darüber, wenn das kein toller Jahresabschluss
ist, liebe Leute. Oder ein toller Jahresanfang.
Oder ein toller Jahresanfang.
Oder in der Mitte des Jahres. Ich denke, wir machen lieber mit der Folge weiter. Okay.
Werbung.
Auf jeden Fall ist es jetzt vorbei, ich bin up to date, ich bin Hochgeschwindigkeits-Florentin, ich bin wieder dabei, ich bin mobil, ich bin smart, ich bin wieder smart und ich habe tatsächlich mal wieder
so ein richtiges Weihnachtserlebnis gehabt,
weil das Schönste an Weihnachten ist ja, dass man
so ein Geschenk hat, an dem man so rumdrücken
kann, so dann irgendwie das Lego-Set,
das man bauen kann oder eine Konsole
und man drückt da halt so rum,
einfach den ganzen Weihnachtsabend drückt man auf
diesem kleinen Ding drum und bei mir war
das einfach schon seit Jahren nicht mehr so, weil ich glaube, letztes Jahr habe ich mir ein Audiointerface gewünscht, mit dem man nichts machen kann, gar nichts. Wo du hellauf begeistert bist, aber alle Verwandten nichts mit anfangen können. Und dann kommt ein netter Onkel, versucht dann auch irgendwie so ein Gespräch darüber anzufangen, merkt aber nach Satz zwei, das führt nirgendwo hin, keine gemeinsame Basis. Ja, ich glaube, das Jahr davor habe ich ein Zelt bekommen, was auch so, ja, bauen wir das auf, nee, bleibt in der Box, ja, ist einfach nichts, gar nichts. Und dieses Jahr hatte ich aber mit meinem neuen Smartphone wieder was und also wenn man, es ist ja verrückt, also es gibt ja immer so, man sagt, oh, das neue iPhone kommt raus und es ist eigentlich genau wie das alte.
Das kann sein, wenn man diese kleinen Schritte immer nur mitmacht, dann wirkt es wahrscheinlich unspektakulär. Aber wenn man mal so fünf Generationen auslässt, holy crap, da kommt schon einiges an Neuerungen zusammen, wo man sich mal so einen Abend mit beschäftigen kann. Allein dieses, wenn du... Ja, exakt, viele Neuerungen. Ja, allein dieses, ich fand das so verrückt mit diesem, wenn man ein Foto macht, macht der automatisch nicht ein Foto, sondern gleich 20 und man kann dann noch in den Fotos so hin und vor und zurück spulen, um den perfekten Frame zu finden. Ja, um das perfekte Foto von mir zu finden. Ja, genau, und dann von 21 Frames die zwei, die nicht unscharf sind, kann man dann finden. Man muss aber auch sagen, dass du nicht das neueste Handy hast, sondern du bist immer jetzt immer noch, jetzt bist du nur noch drei Generationen zurück oder sowas. Ja genau, aber allein das. Du kommst in langsame Schritten näher, aber anstatt jetzt einmal dann all in zu gehen, hast du es wieder nur vertagt, das Problemaufnahme. Ja, aber die ganz aktuellen sind ja super teuer, aber ich habe jetzt wirklich da mit Zeitlupeaufnahme, ich habe die Katze gefilmt, ich hab den ganzen Abend die Katze geärgert, weil wenn so eine Katze dann irgendwo draufhaut mit der Pfote und dessen Zeitlupe, sieht super cool aus, ich hab so viele Zeitlupenfotos, Videos gemacht und dann so diese App, mit der man Sachen messen kann, mit Augmented Reality, da liegt dann auch was auf dem Tisch und du kannst es so abfahren, denn dann misst der, wie lang das ist, unfassbar, unfassbar. Wir sind dieses Opa-Podcast. Ja, wirklich. Also ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie dein kleiner Cousin so ein Rebel-Podcast gerade parallel aufnimmt, so ein jugendlicher Rebellier-Podcast, wo er sich über dich lustig macht und mein anderer Cousin an Weihnachten an dem Handy bekommen ist, die ganze Nacht eine Katze hinterher gelaufene Trottel, während ich am TikTok war. Genau, auf seinem TikTok-Channel macht er irgendwie den Rant über seinen alten dummen Onkel. Über dich. Fantastisch, aber großartig. Und auch jetzt so, dass das Display immer die richtige Helligkeit hat und dass man im Flug, zwar Flugmodus machen kann, aber trotzdem noch Bluetooth anhaben kann. Allein das ist ja genial, das konnte mein altes Handy nicht, da musste ich immer so ... Was? Du konntest im Flugzeug, könntest du nicht Flugmodus anhaben und trotzdem noch neues Gänsel in den Kopf haben? Nee, Flugmodus heißt, alles ist weg. Keine Verbindung mehr zu gar nichts. Ja, Opa, Flugmodus heißt, alles ist weg. Alles ist weg-Modus, wie wir den immer genannt haben. Es ist auf jeden Fall
grossartig. Ich bin sehr glücklich und ich
habe so viel Speicherplatz.
Ich habe so viel Speicherplatz.
Es ist so schön. Aber das stimmt, du hast
recht auf jeden Fall. Man muss eigentlich,
denkt man bei Geschenken, denkt man
zu selten an den Weihnachtsabend
selber. Das ist mir auch wieder aufgefallen.
Und das haben wir auch, glaube ich, schon mal diskutiert. Ich finde es aber auf jeden Fall immer noch mal besprechenswert, weil es kommt darauf an, dass du den Weihnachtsabend gut rumbekommst. Und du musst dir was schenken, was dich den Weihnachtsabend über beschäftigt. Habe ich dieses Jahr wieder verpasst, diese Chance. Ich habe mir auch wieder nichts gewünscht, es wird auch demnächst ein teures Jahr, ich habe mir vor allem Geld gewünscht, so für den Umzug, etc. und habe mir nichts gewünscht, was mich über den Abend
bringt. Und dann kriegt man halt, wenn man halt umzieht
im nächsten Jahr, und die Verwandten wissen das,
kriegt man Handtücher geschenkt, man kriegt ein paar
Küchenutensilien geschenkt und so Dinge, die man
super cool sind, aber mit denen man
so einen Abend sehr schlecht rumbekommt.
Weil willst du dann die ganze Zeit mit deinem Handtuch
rumlaufen oder was?
Also, da wäre auch kein
mit so einem neuen Messer oder willst du mit dem neuen Besteck essen oder das ist doch auch alles Quatsch, aber du brauchst Fummeln, du brauchst Fidgeting-Möglichkeiten. Dein neue Rucksack. Tust Sachen rein und wieder raus und ja, das war's auch. Ja, das war's jetzt. Aber ich dachte mir dieses Jahr, weil Geschenke erziehen ja auch. Geschenke sind eine tolle Möglichkeit und ich habe die Idee gehabt, einer Person einen Soda Stream zu schenken, weil ich dachte, das ist das perfekte Geschenk. Diese Person trinkt andauernd Mineralwasser und so und ich möchte einfach nicht mehr, dass sie Kästen trägt und so weiter. Es ist auch gut für die Umwelt, es ist viel billiger, es ist einfacher und deswegen habe ich einfach dieser Person einen Soda Stream schenken wollen. Jetzt wusste ich aber nicht, wie diese Person zu SodaStreams steht. Also habe ich so im November so die ersten Fragen mal so gestellt. So, ich habe mir jetzt auch diesen SodaStream gekauft, wie ist es denn? Und diese Person hat mir klar zu erkennen gegeben, dass der SodaStream kein gutes Geschenk ist. Weil nee, es schmeckt mir nicht so, ich bin auch sehr wählerisch bei Wasser und so, und ach, das Tragen macht mir auch gar nichts aus, nee, ausser ist meine Küche schon so voll mit so Geräten, keinen Bock auf noch so ein Ding. Wohingegen eine Dartscheibe, die fände ich toll. Und ich dachte irgendwann so, nee, aber ich kann jetzt nicht dafür, diese Person einfach die falsche Meinung. So, und dann habe ich einfach einen Zodastream gekauft, den eingepackt, der Person zu Weihnachten geschenkt und beim Auspacken gesagt, das wird dir jetzt nicht gefallen, ist aber das einzig sinnvolle Geschenk für dich, weil du so viel Mineralwasser trinkst, bitte. Und die Person so, ja, ich weiß schon, was da drin ist. Und dann, zack, Soda Stream. Und, ich hatte,
also es war nicht so schön, also, weil normalerweise,
man schenkt ja auch gerne,
weil jeder Mensch will nur geliebt werden,
und an Weihnachten bist du geliebt, weil du natürlich
irgendwie das auch schon in den Schwarze triffst
mit deinen Geschenken und so weiter, man gibt sich auch Mühe
und so, aber in dem Moment war mir
das scheißegal, ich will nicht geliebt werden,
ich will auch nicht, dass sie jetzt eine gute Zeit hat
oder sowas, nein, sie will einfach nur einen fucking SodaStream haben und ja, jetzt war Weihnachten dann vielleicht nicht so toll und so, aber es war ein nachhaltiges Geschenk, so ich bin halt, ich habe halt sogar noch weiter geschaut, also über den Abend hinaus, weil Weihnachten war hinüber so ein bisschen, muss man sagen, aber jetzt gibt es halt diesen Soda Stream
und er wird benutzt und es ist
doch ganz gut und es ist ja doch ganz lecker
und ja, also es ist ja auch
ein sinnvolles Geschenk, man muss ja auch an die Umwelt denken.
Aber wenn du sagst, er wird benutzt, meinst du,
du benutzt ihn. Ja, ich benutze.
Bei der Person zu Hause immer
Eeeeee!
Da ist doch schön der Soda Stream, oder?
Ah ja, ist doch super! Oh! Und er steht doch super gut neben deinem Sandwichmaker, den anderen zehn elektrischen Geräten. Und guck mal, zehnmal Apfelgeschmack, den mag ich ja sogar ganz gern. Eeeh. Ja, aber ich denke mir, manchmal ist auch Weihnachten ein Geschenk an sich selbst, tut auch mal ganz gut.
Naja, Weihnachten bin ich dreist, da bin ich ganz ehrlich, Weihnachten bin ich dreist. Weil ich finde auch, nur weil das jetzt so ein Fest ist, feste Lieben, feste Liebe, dann muss man doch nicht jetzt Leuten den Arsch kriechen oder sowas, sondern manchmal auch einfach pragmatische Geschenke zu schenken, macht ja auch Sinn. Macht man ja im Rest des Jahres auch. Doch Steaks sind ja eigentlich, wenn man sich mal bewusst wird, so gering. Selbst wenn man mal ein schlechtes Geschenk schenkt, ist es so egal, weil diese Zeit eh so eine Ausnahmezeit ist. Und ich habe noch niemanden gehört, der wirklich ernsthaft böse war wegen einem schlechten Geschenk oder das bis nächstes Jahr verhindert hat. Es ist einfach egal. Im Grunde ist es einfach egal. Aber ich hatte auf jeden Fall eine schöne Zeit. Es ist einfach egal, weil danach Silvester ja auch kommt. Genau. Also weil das ist ja auch einfach so, ihr seht es ja überraschend, wie wenig Zeit eigentlich ist und so. Und es war auch, mein Terminkalender hier in der Heimat war auch eng getaktet. Die ganzen WhatsApp-Gruppen und Google-Doodles waren sehr schwierig einzugeben, weil man hat dann irgendwie ein kleines Zeitfenster hier und ich überschätze das jedes Jahr, weil ich denke mir, wow, da ist ja bestimmt drei Wochen Zeit, aber du hast ja im Endeffekt so drei Tage, wo nicht mit Familie und Weihnachten voll geplant ist und deswegen war auch ein bisschen stressig alles, muss man auch sagen. Silvester steht an, hast du für dich so einen kleinen Jahresrückblick im Privaten schon gewagt? So ein bisschen, wie lief das Jahr, was war? Ja, ich muss sagen, es lief eigentlich ganz gut. Ich habe es dieses Jahr besser hinbekommen, eine Work-Life-Balance hinzubekommen. Das war so ein bisschen mein Ziel auch. Also der Lifestyle-Stefan hat sich dann dort durchgesetzt. Ich habe viel Sport gemacht, ich bin sehr zufrieden mit meiner körperlichen Verfassung. Ich bin auch sehr zufrieden mit meiner geistigen Verfassung, ich habe es hinbekommen, so ein bisschen besser den Spagat hinzubekommen zwischen viel Arbeiten und viel Entlohnung, einem selber mal was Gutes tun, mit Leuten Dinge unternehmen. Da bin ich sehr stolz drauf, weil ich glaube, das ist nicht so einfach in dem, was wir so machen, weil wir so einen sehr klaren Fokus haben auf unseren Job, ist es ja im beidesten Sinne, auch wenn es natürlich ein toller Job ist, etc. Aber es ist natürlich trotzdem so, dass man sein privates Umfeld nicht vergessen sollte. Und das habe ich irgendwie dieses Jahr ganz so drin bekommen. Da bin ich unironisch stolz drauf. Ja, freut mich. Merkt man dir auch an, du bist ... Hast du, wie bischofst du ... Also man hat so ein bisschen das Gefühl, du ziehst dann allen vorbei, so du hast sowohl vom Äusserlichen als auch so von deinem Leben, triffst du die richtigen Entscheidungen und alle anderen stehen so um dich rum und sind so ein bisschen, also ich glaube, ich glaube, der Hass ist dann das grösste Kompliment. Ja. Der Hass auf dich, weil du Sachen hinkriegst, die man eigentlich selber nicht hinkriegt, also nimm das so, wie es gemeint ist. Wenn dich alle hassen und bewusst anrempeln. Ich nimm es mit einem Lächeln und sage Dankeschön. Vielen Dank. Aber wie schaust du auf das Jahr zurück? Weil es ist ja schon noch viel passiert, wir hatten eine sehr krasse Tour. Ich bin immer noch nicht über Notre Dame hinweg, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Das hängt nach irgendwie. Ich glaube, selbst Notre Dame, selbst der Glöckner von Notre Dame ist darüber hinweg. Nee, ich glaube aber selbst so der, jeder, also der Hauself, ich weiß nicht, unsere Konzertaula in der Schule, hat halt einen so einen Grinch, der halt immer die Technik macht, der Dom hat das ja auch, den Dommeister. Und das hat der bestimmt,
der bestimmt auch Notre-Dame.
Ich glaube, der hat das schon vergessen,
dass er mal ein bisschen was gelodert hat.
Da wird das dann wieder aufgebaut und das ist doch gut.
Ja, ich habe auf die Wikipedia-Seite
von 2019 geschaut und das erste
ist halt der brennende Notre-Dame-Turm.
Nicht im Ernst.
Wenn das das Schlimmste war, was das Jahr passiert ist,
dann passt es eigentlich, war okay. Es hat ein Dach gebrannt, aber es war auf jeden Fall ein einschneidendes Erlebnis. Ansonsten ist nicht wahnsinnig viel passiert. Ja, wir haben ein paar Folgen aufgenommen, wir haben getourt, es hat Spaß gemacht und ich bin, es geht heiter weiter. Ich habe mir vorgenommen, ich will... Es geht heiter weiter. Es geht heiter weiter, ich will ein bisschen mehr lesen, ich will ein bisschen weniger Meinungen haben, habe ich mir vorgenommen und vielleicht ein neues Podcastprojekt, ich weiß noch nicht genau, in welche Richtung es geht, aber vielleicht mal wieder das Ernste, vielleicht was aus der Welt der Geschichte. Ich bin gerade so ein bisschen im Geschichtsmodus drin und vielleicht ergibt sich da irgendein Thema.
Oh, das wird dir gefallen, weil wir sind ja immer, das habe ich letztens in einem Buch gelesen, das wird dir gefallen, wir sind ja immer so ein bisschen in Verlegenheit, wenn man manche Gesten beschreiben will.
Also wir sind ja Menschen, die leben durch Sprache und durch Schrift und dann muss man manchmal Dinge beschreiben, die man, wenn man vor jemandem stehen würde, ganz leicht beschreiben könnte, aber Gesten sind manchmal schwer zu beschreiben. So diese Hand waagerecht halten und dann nach links und rechts schlackern, um Gleichgültigkeit anzudeuten. So, das ist immer schwierig, da gibt es keinen guten Begriff dafür. Und nimmt viele Drehbuchseiten in Anspruch auch, weshalb dann immer Leute sagen, deine Drehbücher sind zu lang. Ja, oder so den Zeigefinger und den Daumen an den Spitzen zusammenschliessen und dann an den Mundwinkel halten. Bueno, sowas. Ja, wo die alles Tutti-Tutti-Geste, man trifft ja auch an andere Sprachen ab. Die Tutti-Kompletti-Geste und die Notes vom Studio so, alles gut, nur Seite 84, was? Das ist übrigens ein GIF, das heisst Perfect. Und du bist auf Platz drei der Welt von diesem GIF. Das ist damals aus einem Guter Arbeitssketsch, dem Werner Richter Guter Arbeitssketsch entzogen. Man muss sagen, Julian Laussen, unser Social Media Director, hat da wirklich hervorragende Arbeit geleistet, weil wir früher angefangen haben, die ganzen Gifs zu exportieren und bei Giphy einzureichen. Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach sehr gut getaggt und wirklich andauernd prominente Menschen, also wirklich topnotch DJ Abrams-artige Celebrity-Leute benutzen dich als Perfect Gif. Du bist der Go-To-Perfect-Guy. Was ja eigentlich super ist, weil wir haben ja während guter Arbeit, während guter Arbeit haben wir immer gewitzelt, dass wir am Ende nur noch Gifs machen. Das war immer so am Anfang, ah okay, Funk, super hip und so, und am Ende produzieren wir eh nur Gifs irgendwie und dann, ah, uns wird das Budget so weit gestrichen, dass wir nur noch Gifs machen können. Das war immer so ein Running Gag bei uns, irgendwie so ein bisschen, ja, wir brauchen jetzt Social Media Content, ja, wir drehen heute noch ein Gif oder so. Und ich finde es ganz geil, dass tatsächlich das einzige, was von guter Arbeit Originals übrig geblieben ist, sind die Gifs, die immer noch benutzt werden.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz passend.
Aber was ich sagen wollte, ich habe in einem Buch eine perfekte Formulierung für eine Geste gelesen, wo ich mir dachte, wow, ich weiß nicht, ob der Autor dieses Wort erfunden hat oder ob das tatsächlich in Benutzung ist, aber ich fand es grossartig und mir ist ein Show über den Rücken gelaufen und zwar hat der Autor das Wort benutzt, Kinnrug. Er hat gesagt und er deutete mit einem Kinnrug auf die Frau.
Das ist Wahnsinn!
Wahnsinn! Perfekt. Kinnruck. Ein Kinnruck. Aber das eröffnet jetzt ja alles. Ja. Das eröffnet jetzt ja sämtliche, also wenn man den Ruck noch in die Sprachschublade der Gesten aufnimmt, das macht schon viel aus. Ein Gesichtsrruck. Ja, total. Und jeder weiß, was gemeint ist. Es ist dieses stille Kinnrück. Dieses skeptische, was? Dieses Kinn zurück, weißt du? Ein Kinn zurück Ruck. Das dachte ich erst, wer es. Ach so, ja, das kann auch sein. Das hat dieses skeptische, und dann rutscht das Kinn zurück. Nee, aber ich glaube, er meint definitiv den Kinnruck auf die... Genau, mit einem Kinnruck deuten. Es ist ein bisschen abfälliger als einfach mit dem Kopfnicken deuten oder mit einem, weißt du, dieses Zungen schnalzende. Ja, es ist so ein bisschen geheim, so ein bisschen guck mal da drüben, so. Obwohl es auch ein Stirnruck sein kann, ne? Also es ist nicht immer das Kinn, sondern auch so vom Stirn gerichtet. So, guck mal da drüben. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich glaube, man muss einfach, der Schlüssel dazu ist einfach mehr lesen und auch einfach mehr wagen. Einfach mehr Innovationsgeist wagen bei solchen Begriffen. Ich mag ja auch total, alte Bücher zu lesen, einfach um so ein bisschen in so ein Sprachduktus wieder reinzukommen. Ich lese gerade von Heinrich Heine, das ist total eine total tolle Reiseanekdotensammlung, die Bäder von Lucca. Ich glaube, es ist Lucca, ich weiß nicht genau, das ist eine italienische Stadt. Und da sagt er andauernd, du machst mir glauben. Und das finde ich einen ganz tollen, also das ist auch total, im Englischen gibt es das ja immer noch, to make someone do something, dieses jemanden zu etwas bringen, aber das finde ich verliert man, hat man total verloren, du machst mir glauben. Das finde ich einen ganz tollen Ausdruck, der hat mir glauben gemacht, das sagt man nicht mehr, aber man kann das total gut gebrauchen, glaube ich. Ich habe mich auch schon erwischt, wie ich es ein paar Mal gesagt habe, auf der einen oder anderen Weihnachtsfeier und blöd angeguckt wurde. Ja, oh, der Heine-Leser. Oh, Stefan Heine. Aber ich finde es total ... Trinkt da lieber noch was. Aber vor allem, ich finde es so toll, weil ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Autor in dem Moment bei Kinnrug, hat er das einfach geschrieben, ohne zu wissen, ob das ein bestehendes Wort ist, weil jeder weiß, was damit gemeint ist. Hat er das in dem Moment erfunden oder gab es das schon? Ich weiss es nicht genau, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, das ist so aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, 40er Jahre davor. Und da weiss ich nicht, ob man das da eher gesagt hat, sowas, aber ich kann es mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall toll. Und zum Beispiel bei der letzten Es ist fantastisch. Bei der letzten Folge habe ich geschrieben, war der Text irgendwie die letzte Folge in 2019. Und dann hat jemand geschrieben, das sagt man so nicht, das ist falsch. Das ist Anglizismus. In 2019. The best movie in 2019. Im Deutschen gibt es das nicht. Irgendwas in 2019. Aber ich dachte mir, ist mir scheißegal, weil das ist ein super Wort, das funktioniert gut, weil du musst im Deutschen sonst immer schreiben die letzte Folge des Jahres 2019. Und so schreibst du einfach die letzte Folge in 2019. Und ich war auch mal super pedantisch, was Anglizismen angeht und hab jeden korrigiert, aber mittlerweile denke ich mir so, nee, warum? Jeder Mensch kann sich daran beteiligen, die Sprache zu verbessern und seinen eigenen Stil mit reinzubringen. Macht das, traut euch mal mehr sprachlich! Genau, problematisch ist es dann, wenn man den Sinn verfremdet oder wenn der Sinn sich nicht eins zu eins überträgt. Das denke ich mir auch, ich bin sehr pedantisch bei Kommata, weil die einfach wahnsinnig sinngebend sind. Aber in solchen Fällen, wo jeder versteht,
was du meinst, finde ich es dann auch Quatsch.
Ich finde, da muss sich Sprache auch weiterentwickeln. Und Sprache ist ja
auch ein gemeinschaftlicher Prozess.
Ich finde, Sprache ist wie so ein
gemeinsames Wikipedia-Projekt.
Wie so ein Puffopedia.
Und da hat jeder was beizutragen.
Da muss sich jeder mit einem
Capture anmelden,
kurz auf Ich bin kein Roboter klicken und kann dann alles machen, finde ich.
Also das finde ich auch völlig okay. Kannst auch Einträge löschen und so. Ich finde, der Duden sollte auch so ein Gemeinschaftsprojekt sein. Wo jeder auch Wörter löschen darf. Ja, wo alle alles machen können. Wollen wir ganz kurz in unsere Rubrik gehen? Wikipedia-Beitrag der Woche? Ja, gerne. Der Wikipedia-Eintrag der Woche. Ich habe einen tollen Wikipedia-Eintrag gefunden in der englischen Wikipedia oder in der internationalen Wikipedia, der mich wirklich minutenlang amüsiert hat. Eine tolle Liste. Das sind ja vielleicht immer die besten Wikipedia-Artikel, die Listen. Ah, Listen, generell. Ich gehe auch immer bei so Grammy-Lominierten und so, will man doch immer erst die Liste haben und dann google ich immer Liste, weil du gibst mir die Liste, ich will keinen Text lesen, Liste. Aber ist das eigentlich die Haupt-, die literarische Schriftform unseres Jahrhunderts? Früher war es mal das Gedicht, dann die Ballade oder in antiker Zeit irgendwie der Gesang oder sowas, so Odysseus oder sowas. Ich glaube, die Schriftform der heutigen Generation ist die Liste. Leute lieben Listen. Ja, Liste. Ich glaube, irgendwann schreiben angesehene Autoren auch nicht mehr irgendwie Romane, sondern Listen. Das ist halt einfach dann die neue Kunstform. Und meine Liste der Woche ist, Achtung, List of Film and Television Accidents. Oh, eine grandiose Liste. Und es ist erstaunlich, was bei Filmen und im Fernsehen schon alles passiert ist. Wie viele Leute da sterben regelmäßig. Und es steht tatsächlich, und man ist ja ein bisschen stolz, man ist ja auch ein bisschen stolz, wenn in solchen Listen deutsche Sachen vorkommen. Und es gibt schon einen Eintrag für 2020. Das ging schnell. Und natürlich von Deutschland ist auch Samuel Koch mit drin, in der Sendung Wetten das. Natürlich sehr tragisch, aber ich war ein bisschen stolz. Achtung, ich habe sogar eine Top 3 innerhalb der Liste gemacht. Achtung, auf Platz Nummer 3 ist im Film 7, ja, da gibt es diese Szene, wo Brad Pitt sich bei der Verfolgungsjagd verletzt und dann den Rest des Films verbannt trägt.
Brad Pitt hat sich da tatsächlich verletzt, es war nicht im Skript vorgesehen, dass er sich da verletzt, hat sich tatsächlich verletzt, aber im Skript war vorgesehen, dass er sich an einer anderen Stelle tatsächlich verletzt und ab dann Verband trägt.
Aber er hat sich tatsächlich in dieser Einszene echt verletzt und musste deswegen den Verband tragen.
Also er hat sozusagen dem Skript vorweggenommen.
Auf Platz Nummer zwei, ähm, wieder Brad Pitt.
Gibst du, du hast einfach nur Command F Brad Pitt angegeben.
Brad Pitt hat in einem Film Troja Achilles gespielt und hat sich beim Dreh die Achilles-Szene gerissen. Oh mein Gott! Im Film Passion of Christ hat sich der Darsteller von Jesus, Jim Caviezel, wurde, bevor er die Bergpredigt gedreht hat, vom Blitz getroffen. Oh mein Gott. Oh mein Gott. Wenn das kein Zeichen ist. Falls ihr euch fragt, warum der Film hinten raus so eine sehr, sehr, sehr krasse Botschaft hat, nicht Gottes Lästerung zu begeben. Ja, wem der Film wohl nicht gefallen hat. Stell dir das vor, du bist am Dreh, alles ist da und dann zack, okay, heute Abend Bergpredigt, ab 17 Uhr und batz, Hauptdarsteller wird vom Blitz getroffen. Ach so, ich finde es vor allem lustig, weil es sich anfühlt wie so eine Rache Gottes, weil Gott der Film nicht gefällt über seinen Story und er einfach nicht einverstanden ist und so einen Blitz wirft.
Ich meine, von allen Figuren, die vom Blitz getroffen werden, finde ich, ist Jesus schon relativ bemerkenswert.
Also es ist ein toller Artikel, lest ihn euch mal durch, es ist ein...
Das wusste ich nicht hier, Über kurze Knocked Out einfach. Und es ist faszinierend, wie häufig da auch Leute sterben. Also beim Bau von einem Set oder bei irgendeinem Stunt oder so. Also natürlich, ich meine Hollywood und so, das ist eine riesige Industrie, ist ja klar, dass da Leute sterben, wo in jeder anderen Industrie natürlich auch, aber es ist trotzdem faszinierend. Also lest euch das mal durch, habt einen schönen, schönen Abend, schönen Sonntagabend. Schönen Sonntagabend mit dieser Liste von furchtbaren Unfällen. Aber 2020 gibt es auch schon. Aber nur weil die Filme und die Serien, wo was passiert ist,
ähm, 2020 rauskommen. Aber die wurden schon gedreht. Interessant. Also das finde ich eine coole Liste. Ich habe gerade gesehen, dass der deutsche Eintrag für das Jahr 2020 sehr, sehr voll ist schon, auch mit, oh, nächstes Jahr hat Beethoven zweimal fünfzigzigzigzig, etc. Die englische Version des Eintrags 2020 ist aber nur ganz kurz. Also anscheinend ist Deutschland auch da sehr weit vorne mit dabei, was die Wikipedia angeht, oder? Kann das sein, dass sehr viele Beiträge auf Deutsch sind? Ist ja auch so, dass das Steuerrecht zu einem Drittel, die Weltliteratur des Steuerrechts ist ein Drittel in deutscher Sprache verfasst. Das muss man sich auch mal vorstellen. Ein Drittel der gesamten Literatur auf der Welt, die es über Steuern gibt, ist in deutscher Sprache verfasst. Wahnsinn. Und deutsche Sprache macht ja nicht so wahnsinnig viel aus. Aber ich glaube, auch bei Wikipedia dürfte es ähnlich sein, weil es wirkt wie so ein Wikipedia-Land. Wenn man jetzt den englischen Ich habe auch beschlossen, ich will mehr in die Wikipedia schreiben, weil ich habe schon einen Artikel geschrieben und das hat echt Spaß gemacht und im Grunde ist es ja eigentlich oft nur Dinge, die man in Büchern liest, in die Wikipedia schreiben. Bei den meisten Themen sind ja die Quellen einfach Bücher, gerade bei so historischen Sachen ist es ja einfach Bücher, was immer ein bisschen nervig ist, weil man kann, wenn man dann so einen Wikipedia-Artikel liest und schaut man sich die Quelle an und dann heißt es halt das und das Buch Seite Seite 18, und du denkst dir, ja, ich hab das Buch nicht, das gibt's nicht als E-Book, also was soll ich jetzt machen, soll ich mir das jetzt bestellen? Und deswegen denke ich mir eigentlich immer so, wenn man ein Buch über irgendwas liest und man denkt sich, gibt's jetzt so einen Wikipedia-Artikel zu dem Ereignis oder zu dieser Person und oft nicht und dann einfach schreiben, weil das ist, glaube ich, man hat immer so das Gefühl, dass man Experte sein muss, um Wikipedia-Artikel zu schreiben, aber man kann ja auch einfach Experten abschreiben. Also man kann ja einen Historiker, der ein Buch schreibt, den einfach abschreiben in so einem Artikel. Das führt aber auch dazu, dass man Büchern so einen unglaublichen Wert zumisst in unserer heutigen Zeit, weil Bücher sind so das ultimativ Richtige. Aber das ist ja auch Quatsch, das hat ja auch jemand geschrieben. Weißt du, also irgendwie, man misst gerade Büern so enorm Wert zu, weil das so endgültig wirkt und so, auch die Hemmschwelle, ein Buch zu schreiben ist ja größer als ein Wikipedia-Eintrag zu schreiben.
Aber man bezieht sich die ganze Zeit auf Büchern, aber im Endeffekt hat das ja auch einfach jemand hingeschrieben. Ich weiß nicht.
Ich will mal mit, also, das stimmt, auf jeden Fall.
Also mal ein bisschen rumbullshitten, einfach ein bisschen rumbullshitten und gucken. Leute werden schon, das Korrektiv ist schon gross genug.
Ja, das ist ja auch ein tolles Gefühl, wenn du so einen Wikipedia-Artikel schreibst und dann kommen Leute dazu und fügen dem Dinge hinzu und ändern was und machen neue Referenzen und so, aber dazu muss der Artikel erstmal bestehen. Solange der nicht besteht, ist dieses Wissen ja da, die Leute kennen das ja, aber sie schreiben es nicht nieder.
Und sobald du mal einen Artikel schreibst über eine Person, kommen ganz viele Leute, die sich damit auskennen und neue Verlinkungen machen und so und das weiter ansammeln, aber du musst es erst mal anlegen. Das ist wie so ein wachsender Kristall. Du musst erst mal den Dochter hinhalten und dann wächst da was draus. Nächstes Jahr ist Beethoven ja, am 17. Dezember ist Ludwig von Beethoven 250 Jahre alt. Fantastisch. Das ist für uns vielleicht die Top 3 der Beethoven-Symphonien. Oh, das wird eine grosse Folge. Und vor allem, das wäre mein Traum, 2020 bei uns im Podcast Christian Thielemann. Oh, das finde ich ganz toll. Das wäre so gut. Dann machen wir mit dem zusammen die Top 3 Wagner-Opern und die Top drei Beethoven-Sinfonien. Also das wäre wirklich ein Traum für mich. Ich glaube, der hat jetzt natürlich eine Menge zu tun, gerade im Beethoven-Jahr. Ja, ja, ja, wir auch. Alle haben was zu tun. Ja, gut. Aber vielleicht schaffen wir es. Also falls jemand seine Handynummer hat oder seine E-Mail-Adresse oder sowas oder auf Facebook mit ihm befreundet ist, schreibt uns. Hat Christian Thielemann
Facebook? Ich glaube, der hat eine sehr starke Meinung zu
Facebook. Ja, bestimmt. Ich glaube, der hat zu viel
eine starke Meinung, deswegen will ich ihn auch im Podcast haben.
Aber ist es nicht bei dir
auch so, dass du erst einmal eine Meinung hast,
bevor du jegliches Wissen darüber hast? Also wenn jemand etwas sagt,
mir habe ich schon eine Meinung dazu
und ich hinterfrage die auch erst mal nicht
und es dauert monatelang
diese Meinung, also existiert erst mal so eine Hülse, das ist einfach, habe ich mal so gesagt. Und ich glaube, das ist manchmal so wie das Spiel Werwolf. Also man zieht etwas, man zieht eine Karte und dann handelst du so. Und ich habe das Gefühl, so ist mit Meinungen. Man kriegt dann irgendwo imaginär, ziehst du dann einen, da bin ich dafür oder dagegen Zettel, guckst drauf und dann bullshitest du halt in diese Richtung. Ja, man hätte eigentlich auch eine andere Karte ziehen können, ja. Ja, man hätte eine andere Karte ziehen können und es ist so ein bisschen die Frage, ich glaube, dieses Hinterfragen, das Reflektieren, dann wirklich zu recherchieren und sich eine Meinung zu bilden, hinter der man auch wirklich steht, das kommt fast nicht mehr vor. Aber es ist auch gerne nämlich eine Gegenseite ein. Ich bin ja auch ein Freund des Konfliktes und des Diskurses und so, und vielleicht liegt es auch ein bisschen daran, aber ich habe das Gefühl, erst ist immer die Meinung da, und dann sind immer die Argumente erst da. Das ist was, was ich mir für 2020 vornehme. Ja, ich habe jetzt die Erfahrung gemacht, wie es andersrum ist, weil ich habe das Gefühl, oft entsteht eine Meinung ja erst in der Sekunde, in der man danach gefragt wird.
Also oft ist es so, was meinst du, was hältst du von dem und dem Film? Und in der Sekunde denkst du mir, ja was halte ich denn überhaupt von dem Film? Fuck, fuck, fuck, nee, bei mir ist es fuck, fuck, fuck, ich muss irgendwas sagen, ich muss irgendwas, fand ich toll, toll, toll, toll. Und bei mir war es jetzt so, ich war im Kino hier in München und ich habe Star Wars Episode 9 gesehen. Oh! Ja, ich habe den Film gesehen und ich bin aus dem Kino gegangen und ich dachte mir, Moment mal, ich muss nicht bei Filmfights drüber reden, ich bin nicht bei Kino Plus eingeladen, ich rede mit niemandem erstmal darüber, ich brauche eigentlich gerade keine Meinung zu dem Film. Und ich habe total genossen, es einfach offen zu lassen und nicht wie fandest du ihn? Und dann muss man so sagen, dann muss man sich festlegen, wie du gerade gesagt hast. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, ich schau mal, wie lange ich damit durchkomme, es einfach offen zu lassen. Einfach offen. Und es war total entspannend, dass diese Hürde von einem genommen wird, dass man jetzt irgendwie was dazu sagen muss. Ich mag das auch gar nicht mehr nach. Wann kam die Meinung? Wann kam so kleine Männchen, die gesagt haben, der war grauenhaft, der war doch furchtbar.
Ja, ich wann kam die Meinung? Wann kam so kleine Männchen, die gesagt haben, der war grauenhaft, der war doch furchtbar, der ganze Akt drei macht doch gar keinen Sinn. Ja, ja, ich habe da natürlich schon mir Sachen angehört, auch Antenne Aldera natürlich zu dem Thema und von Red Letter Media, die haben ja auch ein ganz langes Video dazu gemacht und so. Ich habe mir alles angehört, aber ich habe mir trotzdem weiterhin gedacht, so, ich versuche mal es rauszuzögern, mir eine Meinung zu machen. Klar sagt man, okay, manche Sachen hier hat man Einzelmeinungen, aber das ist so mein Ziel, Meinung möglichst lange rauszögern. Aber wo wir gerade bei Wikipedia waren, ich kann, weil ich weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt über Star Wars 9 reden müssen, so jeder kann sich da seine Meinung machen. Das ist nicht der richtige Ort. Genau, hört euch an den Alderan an, da hat Stefan genug dazu gesagt, falls ihr es wissen wollt. Aber ich bin ja, ich habe ja so ein bisschen so ein Podcast, ich bin so ein bisschen weird mit Podcasts. Es gibt manche Podcasts, die höre ich immer nur zu ganz speziellen Zeiten. Einschlafen. Ja, weiss ich nicht, es gibt einen Podcast, den höre ich immer nur in München. Und das finde ich ganz cool, weil ich verbinde München total mit dem Podcast und den Podcast total mit München. Und ich freue mich immer drauf, wenn ich in München bin, dass ich den Podcast wieder hören kann. Und das ist so, auch die Intromusik, da bin ich dann total da. Und den will ich hier auch mal empfehlen, habe ich ein paar Mal schon gemacht, und zwar ist der Reply All, das ist ein Podcast, wo es um Internetthemen geht und ganz viele verschiedene Geschichten aus dem Internet und wie Menschen mit dem Internet umgehen und wie das Internet mit Menschen umgeht. Und da gibt es auch eine Folge von einem Wikipedia-Editor, der nur sich zur Lebensaufgabe gemacht hat, einen einzigen grammatikalischen Fehler auf der Wikipedia zu korrigieren. Und er hat schon zehntausende Edits und unendlich viele Edits gemacht und diesen einen grammatikalischen Fehler zu korrigieren. Ich bin jetzt nicht so firm in Englisch, aber es geht um den Begriff Comprised Of. Und anscheinend gibt es da eine Bedeutung, die korrekt ist und eine Bedeutung, die viele Leute haben und denken, dass es die bedeutet, aber die falsch ist. Und ich glaube, es heißt so viel wie besteht aus mehreren Elementen. Irgendwas ist comprised of und dann verschiedene Elemente. Aber es wird auch anders benutzt. Und es gibt, und die haben ein Interview gemacht mit diesem Typen. Und es ist halt schon interessant, weil der sagt halt, das ist so sein Ding, dass er das halt zehntausendmal macht. Und momentan ist es so als grammatikalische Regel. Und dann wird er in dem dem Interview auch gefragt, so ja und was ist jetzt, wenn diese grammatikalische Regel geändert wird, weil viele Leute es anders machen und dann war wirklich so ein, ja dann ja dann war alles umsonst so, das ist auch so geil, weil der sich auch so bewusst ist, wie sinnlos das ist und der hat er hunderttausende Stunden hineinversetzt, aber dem ist auch so bewusst, dass es so auf der Kippe steht, dass alles kompletter Unsinn ist. Und das ist ganz toll, und da gibt es ganz, ganz viele tolle, verschiedene Folgen, Reply All, und hört euch das an, das ist auf jeden Fall grossartig. Dann möchte ich auch noch gerne eine Podcast-Show empfehlen. Tu es. Und zwar etwas, was ich die ganze Zeit gerne klauen wollen würde für den deutschen Markt. Und ich habe noch nicht den richtigen Host gefunden, weil ich selber schaffe das zeitlich nicht, weil es auch sehr viel Zeit in Anspruch nimmt. Es gibt auch nur, glaube ich, sechs Folgen oder sieben Folgen, aber The Mystery Show würde ich sehr gerne empfehlen. The Mystery Show ist ein fantastisches kleines Format von Gimlet, glaube ich.
Ja, Reply All ist auch von Gimlet, ja.
Und es ist fantastisch, weil es ist einfach eine Journalistin, die ist auch noch gar nicht so alt, hat viele tolle Artikel auch geschrieben, so Faiton-Kulturkram. Und die will einfach nur ganz kleine Rätsel, ganz kleine Mysteries aus ihrem privaten Umfeld lösen. Zum Beispiel eine Autorenfreundin von ihr hatte einmal ein sehr, hatte zwei Bücher geschrieben, ein, das erste Buch war wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig erfolgreich und das zweite Buch war der grösste Flop. Und um das zu beweisen, ruft sie dann auch bei ganz vielen Buchhandlungen an und so und sie können es nirgendwo kaufen. Man kann es einfach nicht mehr bekommen, dieses Buch, weil es so ein großer Flop war. Aber, und das ist das Mystery dann, was es zu lösen gilt, es gibt ein Paparazzi-Foto von Britney Spears, die dieses zweite Buch ihrer Freundin in den Händen trägt und offensichtlich gelesen hat oder zumindest geschenkt bekommen hat oder gekauft hat. Und dann geht es darum, dann fragt die Freundin sie und es ist dann wirklich aufgebaut wie Serial, also wirklich knallharte Recherche. Es sind immer so ganz, ganz kleine Dinge, die immer wahnsinnig toll gross aufgebauscht werden. Und da geht es einfach darum, wie kam Britney Spears an dieses Buch? Hat sie es gelesen und wenn ja, gefiel ihr das Buch? Und dann gibt es eine grosse Recherche und es wird nicht so ganz toll dokumentarisch aufgemacht, viel zu gross für diese kleine Frage. Und das ist eigentlich auch das, worum es geht, so ganz viele zwischenmenschliche Momente, die so toll sind, die ja konserviert werden in diesem Podcast, wo es einfach Anrufe bei Hotlines, Anrufe bei Büchereien, ob die das Buch haben, dann will ich nicht zu viel verraten, aber es gibt dann geht dann in Richtung Meet and Greet und da wird, da ruft sie bei der Hotline an, um herauszufinden, ob sie Zeit mit Britney hat und wie viel Zeit mit Britney hat. Und der Weg ist einfach das Ziel. Es geht nicht um die Antwort, es geht darum, welchen Leuten sie auf diesem Weg dahintrifft. Und das ist wirklich ganz fantastisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob das alles authentisch ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall fantastisch gespielt, wenn es nicht echt ist und wahnsinnig authentisch gespielt. Und das ist so ein toller Podcast und es gibt ganz viele kleine Rätsel des Alltags. Und ich würde wahnsinnig gern, das mal in Deutschland machen, weil es leider auch nur ein paar Folgen gibt und ich finde, das ist ein fantastisches Format, was viel länger tragen würde. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine tolle, eine grossartige Empfehlung.
Klingt sehr cool, The Mystery Show.
The Mystery Show.
Hört es euch mal an, ihr habt jetzt noch ein paar Tage Zeit, bevor das neue Jahr losgeht und die Realität euch wieder erfasst.
Und bis dahin könnt ihr noch ein bisschen geniessen und Podcasts hören und alles.
Und eine Empfehlung will ich noch loswerden, Netflix, und zwar, wir müssen ja so ein bisschen hier die Zauberei hochhalten. Du hast ja auch gesagt, du bist großer Zauberfan, Penn & Teller und sowas. Und es gibt eine neue Zauberershow auf Netflix, Magic for Humans. Fantastisch! Meine Herren, habe ich diese Serie weggebinged und hatte ich eine Freude dabei. Habe ich noch nicht gesehen, das ist mir sogar empfohlen. Zwischen den Jahren kam eine Nachricht von Florentin, hat mich sehr gefreut. Ich habe es noch nicht geschafft, aber freue mich sehr drauf. Schaust du dir heute an, es ist toll, es ist auch toll geschnitten und es ist lustig. Bei manchen Zaubertricks bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob das wirklich Magie ist oder nicht, aber teilweise sind die so unglaublich, dass ich mir denke, das muss gefakt sein, aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen gerade bei so Shows auch ein bisschen die Gefahr von so Zauberern, die sich denken, wenn mein Trick richtig gut ist, denken die Leute einfach, es ist gefakt, es ist einfach geschnitten oder die Leute sind eingeweiht. Genau, du musst die Möglichkeit haben, ja, ist ja auch bei Prestige ein großes Problem, es darf ja nicht zu komplex sein, weil irgendwann ist das Rätsel größer als die Freude über den Trick. Und ich bin aber sehr anfällig dafür, deswegen habe ich immer Angst, dass ich den Trick kaufe. Literally. Ich bin gespannt. Geld ausgebe, um den Trick zu haben. Um den Trick zu haben, genau. Naja, auf jeden Fall, das sind doch gute Empfehlungen fürs nächste Jahr,, beziehungsweise jetzt noch für zwischen den Jahren. Ich freue mich auf jeden Fall wahnsinnig auf das nächste Jahr mit dir. Ich habe mich auch selber dieses Jahr gefreut. Thais haben wir dieses Jahr kennengelernt zum Beispiel. Auch von Thais wünschen wir euch allen einen guten Rutsch und einen guten Start ins nächste Jahr auf jeden Fall. Ja, macht's gut. Glaube ich mal einfach. Ist eine sehr gerade so eine rebellische Phase, wo sie irgendwie Silvester oder die Sonne in Frage stellt oder sowas. Ja, dieses ganze Konsumzeug wird sie wahrscheinlich eh ablehnen. Von daher ziehe ich das in ihrem Namen auch wieder zurück. Sie wünscht weder frohe Weihnachten noch ein gutes neues Jahr. Das würde ich auch gerne zurückziehen, es tut mir leid. Aber wir beide wünschen das und ja, kommt gut rein und wir freuen uns auf ein tolles 2020 mit dem Podcast so von euch.
Und vielen Dank an Leon für das fantastische Intro.
Macht's gut, ciao, wir heben das ab. Macht's gut, ciao, ciao.